hey everyone sarah pasco's had a very
exciting lockdown
exciting have i yeah have i well haven't
you
oh yeah well i got married just
beforehand so i've had a very exciting
yeah time it should have been kind of
like the the new you know
married bliss and everything and then
there was a lockdown and we were stuck
together and the flat all of the time
and um and it's not a very um it's not
very good for romance
so i decided i would do something to
kind of keep the romance going and
what i did was very cliche i bought some
sexy pants
on a website and i brought them to show
you
this is not unhygienic by the way
because they've never been worn
because they're too complicated
and if you can see that um you see how
there's too many leg holes
this is the pants that i brought they
were very expensive
and also i showed one of my friends that
showed lou and she was like oh they're
crotchless they're not i promise
that's the crotch there they do have a
crutch
a batch for me nashville um so there we
go and um
and so they first arrived i didn't know
it was going to be so difficult so i
just sent my husband out like oh
come in the bedroom in five minutes
you'll get a nice surprise and i just
i'll just put my pants on cause i've
never had trouble before you know
um just assume it's going to be easy i
wasn't wearing shoes i should say it
wasn't as complicated
and then i realized oh no there's always
other leg spaces
and i thought oh maybe it's for arms
[Laughter]
so those kind of arm pants okay maybe
that's why they're so
sexy and um and first of all
i was just you know very confused about
it and then um
then i got annoyed and then um i felt
lonely
and eventually i got you know very
frustrated and angry and i started
crying
and and my husband was at the door kind
of like let me in what's wrong i can't
get these pants on
and then he was like he's australian
like oh i'll show you
because i think he thought i was being
really stupid and like he would just
show me how to put on
underwear and then he came in and then
he was flummoxed as well
and then he asked like what website did
you get him from
and so i told him and then he found the
page and he like shoved his phone in my
face
and and i was looking at this woman and
she was much much
younger than me much thinner with very
big boobs and she was
all shiny with oil and she must have
been like a mensa member because she was
wearing these
and he was like that's what they're
supposed to look like
the sex was cancelled
you